you put a boy in the hospital it was  self-defense Your Honor you will be  remanded to a detention center that  specializes in helping girls like  yourself get that temper under control  [Music]  I've got a sergeant Robert Reese  let's get you processed I hear your  junior chance I think someday you could  be in Olympia need a little time to  straighten out that's what you can go  it's dying out there that's the only way  they learn what kind of place are you  guys running here  keep your face shot how long am I here  for that's up to the judge what is it  payments from the state  we're assigned a bed before we even have  a trial this looks like drug money or  something we're gonna end them  [Music]  [Music]  after this game  what they'll do is give you back what  you took  [Music]  always need my help Barney  [Music]  you  [Music]  you